now we told you a few minutes ago about
several Special Operations veterans who
are undertaking a truly historic effort
to skydive in seven continents in seven
days
Mike Glover is now with us he will be
talking a little bit more about Legacy
Expeditions which is organizing this
effort he has worked with a lot of these
guys for a long time we had some mic
problems earlier but they're fixed now
so I'm glad Mike could stick around and
tell us more Mike thank you so much for
coming back
talk about the significance of what
these guys are doing I know they're
starting in Antarctica they're on their
way there if they're not there already
where do they go next
so they're they're going to Antarctica
and making their way to Chile and it's
all all seven continents culminating in
Florida and Tampa Florida the overall
objective here is to take veteran
Special Forces and Special Operations
skill sets and Inspire Americans to
never forget the sacrifice these Special
Operations and and and people who who
never had the opportunity to come back
that we should never forget about them
and offer the educational benefits the
scholarships through folds of Honor for
their family members
so people can follow along on this
historic event and help support this
amazing non-profit and effort to support
those who have lost their loved ones
where where do they go and how do they
do that
say they can go to
legacyexpeditions.net that's the primary
place where they could donate we've
already raised 150 000 and like I said
before I'm not sure if you guys heard it
but if we raise seven million dollars
that helps 1400 different families with
scholarships for those
um that their loved one never came back
from war so we want to do our best to
bring attention to it and break in a
couple World Records is our attempt
I appreciate you Mike uh your lifetime
of service and those of your brothers
who are out on this Mission now thank
you again and we look forward to
following along
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight